un acto de traición o una trampa según
el Washington post El propietario y
fundador del grupo Wagner jefgen y
perygosin supuestamente ofreció revelar
las posiciones de las tropas rusas al
gobierno ucraniano en enero a cambio de
que kiev retirara sus tropas de mahmud
donde Los mercenarios de Wagner llevan
meses pagando un alto precio en la
guerra en curso el oligarca ruso
calificó las acusaciones de tonterías
también negó las afirmaciones de haberse
reunido con el jefe de la inteligencia
militar ucraniana en un país africano y
sugirió que algunos miembros de la élite
moscovita le estaban tendiendo una
trampas puedo decir con certeza que no
he estado en África al menos desde el
comienzo del conflicto en Ucrania e
incluso en los meses anteriores al
inicio de la operación militar especial
por lo que no pude reunirme físicamente
con nadie así
las afirmaciones del Washington post se
basan en documentos secretos
estadounidenses filtrados a la
plataforma de chat de grupos discord en
abril las acusaciones se producen
después de que pregocen denunciara
públicamente a varios altos cargos del
mando militar ruso acusándoles de
retener munición y armas a sus hombres
por su parte el kremlin ha rechazado las
acusaciones calificándolas de rumores
no no puedo comentar nada pero parece
otra noticia falsa
desgraciadamente incluso los periódicos
respetados en el pasado se han
acostumbrado a esto
por su parte Washington se ha negado a
comentar el informe del periódico